Let's give it up for this
amazing crowd tonight.
What's up, Boston?
Woo-hoo!
[CHEERING]
(SINGING) Do what I
want 'cause I can,
if I don't, because I wanna.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We have four bands
competing tonight.
They each get a
15-minute set, and then
at the end of the night, the
judging panel comes together
and decides on a winner.
Good job.
Sounded great.
That winner gets 50%
of the charity proceeds
for their charity of choice.
(SINGING) We will,
we will rock you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
The idea behind the Battle
of the Biotech Bands
has to do with doing
what we can for children
and their families who
are fighting diseases,
here and around the world.
(SINGING) Don't you
forget about me.
We know there are
patients out there
who are in dire need of serious
treatment for serious diseases.
And so any little
bit that we can
do, whether it's through our
work or through music, passions
that we have, we just want
to come out and rock it.
(SINGING) Aaaaah, ah,
ah-ah-ah-ah, yeah.
The creativity here
tonight is an example
of the creativity that
goes on in the workplace
and in those laboratories.
If you guys do your science
as well as you do your music,
we've got nothing
to worry about here.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
In the Boston area,
biotechnology literally
takes center stage.
And you don't have to
look far to see why.
That's because the region
is home to the biotechnology
capital of the
world, Kendall Square
in Cambridge, Massachusetts.
Here, in less than
one square mile,
clustered around the
Massachusetts Institute
of Technology, are more than
100 biotechnology companies,
nearly all of the world's
top pharmaceutical firms,
and millions of square
feet of lab space.
Groundbreaking
drugs developed here
have already touched the lives
of 2 billion people worldwide,
and more treatments
are in the pipeline.
Kendall Square is simply
the densest collection
of life scientists in
the known universe.
We're making big
inroads in cancer.
We'll make big inroads
in Alzheimer's.
We'll make big inroads in
ALS, and many other diseases.
But just a few decades ago,
this industry and the science
underlying it didn't exist.
Kendall Square was
a desolate landscape
of shuttered manufacturing
plants and vacant lots.
When I arrived here in
1960, Kendall Square
looked a bit like a war zone.
It was an area
that was deserted.
And beyond getting on and
off at the train station,
people typically
didn't go there.
And now, when you
walk down the street,
there are young,
excited people who
are racing to get someplace,
busy at some piece of inventing
the future.
It's dynamic.
It's energetic.
It's vibrant.
It's innovative.
It's dense.
You bump into people
a lot, which I think
is the beauty of the place.
So what brought about
this dramatic change?
How did this
industry that affects
so many lives and drives the
economy of an entire region
arise in such a
short period of time?
And why here, in such an
unlikely-seeming area?
I hesitate to say that
there was a logic to it.
It was not a deliberate path
that led us to where we are.
There was a lot of courage.
People really were willing
to follow the science,
take risks, to dare to do things
that otherwise are completely
unthinkable.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
They drove me to Rockefeller
on this day in July 1962.
Eventually, the person
living in the next room
introduced himself.
He was a hippie.
He had long hair, white
clothes, sandals, unshaven.
My mother peeked into the room,
and it was a bit of a mess.
And her parting
words to me were,
Harvey, he's not our kind, I
don't want you to have anything
to do with him.
However, 13 years later, when
David Baltimore won the Nobel
Prize, it was all over
Cleveland, my son's best friend
just won the Nobel Prize.
When I came here in
1960, we were just
starting molecular biology
we had no reputation
as a school of biology.
No one even knew
that MIT did biology.
Today, biology permeates
every part of MIT.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Biology meant everything.
It meant the kingdoms
and the phyla
and it meant physiology
and strange creatures.
[INSECTS CHIRPING]
Until that time, biology was a
collection of unrelated facts
and observations,
rather than a discipline
governed by a small set
of unifying principles.
Watson and Crick discovered
the structure of DNA
in 1953 with the data
from Rosalind Franklin.
MIT's leadership recognized
that this was the unifying
concept for biology.
MIT said, we just
can't do everything.
We're going to focus just
on molecular biology.
Molecular biology was a view
of biology as an information
science.
And the information
was encoded in DNA.
It's just about then that
Salvador Luria, a refugee
from Italy, came to MIT.
Salvador Luria, who the next
year won the Nobel Prize,
was really the heart and soul
of the MIT biology department.
Luria had a vision
that all of biology
was going to be transformed
by a molecular approach
to questions about
living systems.
And what happened
in the early 1960s
was this brilliant flash of
insight on the part of many
that one could really
understand everything
if one really understood the
details of how cells were
organized, how they turned
on and off different genes
and proteins.
The year was 1963.
The genetic code was
still being cracked.
Jim Watson would
come to class talking
about DNA and this
revolution which
is called molecular biology.
And I'm listening, and
at the end of the hour,
I'm a different person.
My life has been redirected.
And it was clear that he
was literally telling us
the secret of life, and how
everything biological gets made
and why it works
the way it does.
With this scheme of DNA
makes RNA makes proteins,
one could explain
the entire biosphere
with a very simple
conceptual structure.
What molecular
biology had given us
was the ability to study
the molecules that determine
the properties of life.
I thought one day,
people will be
able to work on cancer
at the molecular level.
They'll be able to understand
how cancer comes about
by studying genes.
More people each year die of
cancer in the United States
than all the Americans who lost
their lives in World War II.
Richard Nixon was elected
president in 1968.
And he's very concerned about
being re-elected in 1972.
And so Nixon says he will
declare a war on cancer,
and push for legislation in
1971 as a way of preempting this
as an issue in the
presidential election.
This funding by Nixon
was critically important
because Luria
correctly perceived
that the war on
cancer would offer him
some largesse in building
up the MIT Cancer Center
and in recruiting faculty.
We built the Cancer
Center in an old candy
factory, which MIT owned.
It was a very audacious
idea that molecular biology
was going to have
an impact on cancer.
I was recruited to
a faculty position.
And I thought, wow,
I hadn't thought
about that, because
that was something
that women just didn't do,
really, in my generation.
When I wanted to go
into work on cancer,
my friends said, goodbye,
we'll never see you again,
because you could
bring molecular biology
to this problem, but it didn't
mean it was going to work,
that you were going
to get anywhere.
The assumption at the
time was, if we understood
the causes of cancer,
we would surely
be able to treat the disease.
We had a very intense
research group
on the fifth floor of the Center
for Cancer Research at MIT.
Oncogenes were discovered, and
the functions of cancer genes
were discovered, and the
fact that some of these genes
were active in human
tumors was discovered,
and how viruses cause
cancer was discovered.
And it was one
discovery after another.
The legend on the campus was
the lights never went out
on the fifth floor
of the cancer center.
There was always somebody
in the laboratory
working, 24 hours a day.
The MIT Cancer Center ultimately
had four Nobel laureates--
Baltimore, Luria, Susumu
Tonegawa, and then Phil Sharp.
It was an extraordinary
powerhouse,
and represented the
wave of the future.
Luria brings his team in.
They renovate an
old candy factory.
They're about to get started.
And then there's a crisis.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Scientists, including
many at MIT,
developed technologies for
isolating individual genes,
learning how to take these
genes, put them in cells,
and then make a lot
of the protein that
was coded by the gene.
For the first time,
man had the ability
to make a biological
organism that
may not have ever
appeared before
in the biological kingdom.
And that was recombinant DNA.
It was an exciting advance
because it really opened up
new ways to be able to
study human genetics.
This was new technology
at a world historic level,
like making steel or
petrochemical industry.
It wasn't just a little
technical advance,
it was going to be a
whole new industry.
This represented the first time
one could splice together genes
from, for example, humans
with the genes of bacteria,
a very unnatural juxtaposition.
That led to a lot of debate
about how this should be done.
Should it even be done?
What could be the consequences?
What powers would come
with this new technology?
And this conjured up all
kinds of horrible scenarios
that might spawn
different kinds of plague.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Doctor, you were the one
who got this particular kind
of research started,
and then you
spoke out about the
possible dangers of it.
What happened that
caused you to do that?
Well, we could
foresee that there
was going to be great
interest in this technique,
and that many people were
excited about the opportunities
that was created by it.
We could also see that some
of the experiments that
might be done might
perhaps create
some dangerous situation.
I started getting telephone
calls calling me a monster
for actually creating
molecules that could possibly
be very deleterious to humans.
Any new capability carries
with it a potential danger,
but we weren't actually sure
what the range of danger was.
In fact, some people
thought there really
wasn't much danger, and
that natural processes
would counter the
synthetic processes
that we had developed.
So you have all these
other agendas that
begin to pile on top of this--
people who are
frightened that this
might have risks to humans,
and other people who
are saying this is
an industrial realm
that we must not surrender.
Science had been
moving incredibly fast,
beyond the ability
of the general public
to assess it, to understand
it, become comfortable with it.
Many of us felt that we needed
to take some kind of action.
And so the first
thing was a moratorium
on those experiments.
So we called for our scientists
throughout the world to pause,
to temporarily defer
certain experiments
until we could meet
and discuss the nature
of the possible hazards and
the kinds of experiments that
could or should not be done.
The moratorium was remarkably
respected all around the world.
Never in history had a group
of scientists come together
and said, we will not do x.
We called for a conference.
And that was the quite
famous Asilomar meeting
that was held in a conference
center in California.
That was going to be an
international conclave
to consider the risks and to
try to set forth some principles
for regulating research.
There were approximately
150 scientists
from around the world.
And we also invited some
lawyers, some ethicists.
We invited members of the press.
They were every bit as much
involved in the conference
as were the scientists.
Every evening, we
had big beer parties.
And so there was people
mixing and talking.
We wanted this to be open.
We didn't want anybody to think
we were some secret cabal.
It was an extraordinarily
passionate and even contentious
meeting.
Everybody was sort
of pointing fingers.
It's not my work
that's dangerous.
How could that be dangerous?
It's your work that's dangerous.
Don't tell me what
I can do, can't do.
So there was a lot of
that back-and-forth.
The ethicists and
the lawyers made
it very clear that there were
very severe personal risks.
Everybody who came of
the so-called experts
thought the risks were very
small, but they're not zero.
If it's not zero and there
is some potential risk,
and you can't really
quantify it or identify it,
the best thing to do is go slow.
The scientists
stop talking about
if they should do the research.
They start talking about
how to do the research.
In essence, the proposal
was called on the NIH
to develop a series
of guidelines
that would instruct
people on how
to do these experiments safely.
The final statement
of that conference
did serve as a basis for the
National Institutes of Health
to promulgate some regulations
of the field, which
they did in late June of 1976.
By and large, recombinant
DNA became doable.
If you followed the guidelines,
there was no problem.
What they hadn't
necessarily counted on
is that individual communities
might become concerned.
And that's where
Cambridge City Council
says we don't trust the federal
government to make decisions
about work that's being done
within the bounds of the city
of Cambridge, which
really sets up
one of the most dramatic
cases of scientists
and the concerned public
confronting each other over how
to regulate this technology
anywhere in the nation.
My research involved
recombinant DNA technology.
I contributed to that
technology while I was at MIT.
I had some very interesting
experiments I wanted to do.
And then there was a
continuation of the moratorium
here in Cambridge.
But let me assure you that
every city in the United
States of America and
throughout the world
is now discussing the DNA
experimentation in their cities
and towns and
villages and hamlets.
The hall was full of citizens
of Cambridge and scientists
from MIT and Harvard.
I'm standing in the
balcony, because the hall
was totally full, watching
Mayor Vellucci here hold forth.
Most of us in this
room, including myself,
are lay people.
We don't understand
your alphabet.
So you will spell
it out for us so
that we know exactly what
you're talking about.
The debate itself came out of
academia originally, really
as questions raised
by some biologists
about the work of
other biologists.
My name is Jonathan King.
I'm associate professor
of biology at MIT.
I have been concerned with this
issue for a number of years.
They essentially went to
city council and said,
we don't know the answers
to these uncertainties,
and we think that it's
a community issue.
It was said that there
was no danger of escape.
I'd like to go down
on record as saying
that's a patently
false statement.
In fact, it is absolutely
certain that they will escape.
We wanted regulation, as
existed for many other hazardous
materials in American society.
The risks in this case
are purely hypothetical.
Not only has no known dangerous
organism ever been produced,
but I believe it
to be the opinion
of the overwhelming
majority of microbiologists
that there is, in fact, no
significant risk involved
in experiments authorized to be
done by the federal guidelines.
There was a reasonably wide
held belief in Cambridge
that federal agencies
may not always
have the best interests
of the community in mind.
You've got to see it in the
shadow of the atomic bomb,
because that was the singular
event in which the public
suddenly became aware that
science had done things
that they never conceived of.
And they kept worrying that
there was an atomic bomb hidden
away in modern biology.
The mayor of Cambridge became
quite alarmed by the rhetoric -
visions of viruses and germs
or cloned creatures taking
over the streets or
infecting us or worse.
I have made references
to Frankenstein
over the past week,
and some people
think this is all a big joke.
That was my way of describing
what happens when genes
are put together in a new way.
This is a deadly serious matter.
If worse comes to
worse, we could have
a major disaster on our hands.
So it was very dramatic.
You know, in that
environment, you know,
you say things that, you know,
maybe you wish you hadn't said.
I don't think those
guidelines were written
by a group of people who
represented the public and all
the interests.
Those guidelines are like having
the tobacco industry write
guidelines for tobacco safety.
I'm kind of proud of it, even
though many of my colleagues
wouldn't talk to me.
This country, this
community has not
decided that we should go
ahead with this research.
It is very dangerous.
It's very questionable.
Be it resolved that the
Cambridge City Council insists
that no experimentation
involving recombinant DNA
should be done within
the City of Cambridge
for at least two years.
[APPLAUSE]
[BOOS]
Here at the moment,
we could unleash
a whole new powerful tool
to answer our questions.
No.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Had there been
something that happened,
an organism created
that disseminated itself
through Cambridge
and maybe the world,
we would have been
blamed for that,
and it would have brought
a halt to the direction
of modern biology,
modern science.
So there was a tremendous
amount at stake.
Powerful forces were at play.
The venture capitalists
were already there
in the background
watching and waiting.
The mayor appointed a
commission of ordinary citizens
to answer one simple
question-- are these scientists
being honest with us?
Is the process that was
put in place at Asilomar
a process that is going to
safeguard the community?
That was a novel reality
for the academic community.
They were not accustomed to
citizens perceiving themselves
as equal partners in the
development of science.
In the end, they decided
that they thought
the processes that were being
developed at the National
Institutes of Health
were appropriate
and that this technology
was the future of biology
and should be freed.
It took about a year to go from
the first city hall meeting
to the position in
which we could really
begin to plan to do those
experiments in Cambridge.
The ban on using
recombinant DNA was lifted,
and that resulted
in an explosion
of biomedical
research, because it
was such a useful
technological innovation.
The then-mayor of Cambridge,
in a reaction to this activism,
led the creation of the
nation's very first zoning
rules for a biotech-related
research development,
leading this as a way of
controlling the growth
of biotech in Cambridge.
In fact, it had the
opposite result,
which was creating
predictability
for the industry.
Where there was
no predictability
in zoning in development across
the United States of America,
there was in Cambridge.
There was in Kendall Square.
And that's one of the
reasons why Cambridge
got out ahead of so
many other areas,
because we had a
blueprint that set out
what could be done in the city.
It liberated Harvard
and MIT to move forward
and to become centers
of the new biology.
When Biogen came to
Cambridge and applied
for the first
recombinant DNA license
in a commercial
organization in Cambridge,
Cambridge said, we've
gone through this debate.
People in Cambridge know
what the issues are.
We have these guidelines.
If you adhere to
these guidelines,
like the universities,
we're fine.
And Mayor Vellucci showed up
for the opening of the Biogen's
first laboratory in Cambridge
and cut the ribbon and said,
you know, I like
recombinant DNA experiments,
particularly when
they pay taxes.
And that led to human insulin.
That led to human
growth hormone.
That led to interferons
for infectious disease
and multiple sclerosis, and it's
led to treatments of cancer.
And it's just an extraordinary,
extraordinary breakthrough.
So what we had, then,
were a few small companies
that really provided the
nucleus for a biotech industry
in Kendall Square.
The early days,
people were guessing
as to whether it would
take 10 years or 2 years
to be able to make a particular
protein in pure form,
and the FDA didn't even have
guidelines as to how they
would regulate new products.
And those guidelines
kept changing,
and so it was kind of a
real wild west moment.
It was really the
birth of an industry.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
From these roots
in recombinant DNA,
a lot of interesting
things happened.
One is the cures.
For a long time,
the industry was
very hesitant about
using the "cure" word,
but we've gotten to the point
where if we're not eradicating,
we're substantially and
dramatically improving
the lives of individuals
with rare disease.
So that's a real
visceral impact.
I began working on the
intellectual property,
the patents mostly, for
the fledgling Biogen, who,
at that time, had no employees.
They were basically
seven or eight scientists
in their labs around
Europe and the US.
Biogen started by two
venture capitalists.
They had a fantastic idea.
Get the best scientists
from all over the world
and start a company.
A biotechnology firm that
starts could probably
expect to take 10 years before
its product came to market.
That's 10 years
before any profit,
and it's 10 years of needing
an immense amount of money
to sustain this operation.
And the probability of
success, historically,
has been about 5%, so when you
have these incredibly risky
investments, you're
going to have
a challenge in
being able to raise
the proper kind of
financing to fund them.
Biotech was the
first example where
Wall Street was willing
to fund new technology
over a long period of
not being profitable
to own part of the company
when it became profitable.
What really put
Biogen on the map
was the cloning of interferon.
It really was this holy
grail of biotechnology.
Interferon is a natural compound
produced by the body when
it is infected by a virus.
It seemed to kill
viruses, kill cancers.
It was amazing.
But you couldn't
get enough of it.
And because it was
so unavailable,
there grew up a bunch of
myths about how potent
it was going to be, and it's
going to be a cure for cancer.
And Biogen set that as
one of their projects
to try to clone
it and produce it.
We came to an agreement
with Charles Weissman,
one of the founders
of molecular biology,
that he would develop a
research program to clone
the gene for alpha interferon.
We didn't have a
lab, and those of us
who undertook projects undertook
to do them in their university
labs.
On Christmas Day, 1979,
Charles is up in Davos,
where he skis over the
holidays with friends,
and back in his lab is
Nagata, who's a postdoc.
Nagata was extremely
hard-working,
and within a few
months, he was then
successful in actually cloning
the cDNA of interferon alpha.
Nagata calls Charles
and says he thinks
he's seen a positive out of one
or two of the bacteria colonies
he was assaying.
When Charles cloned and
expressed interferon,
it was a world-shaking
event, and we thought
it will cure everything.
I flew to Switzerland
immediately
and spent the next two weeks
writing the patent application,
because we knew we're in a race.
We knew other
companies were trying
to clone interferon as well.
We, as a scientific
advisory board,
had talked the company into
having our January meeting
in the Caribbean.
And the first day
of the meeting,
Charles gets up and
explains what he's done
and the evidence that
this is alpha interferon
that he has the gene for.
And we were just astounded.
The board, at the time,
wanted to publicize this,
because it would boost
the share price of Biogen.
And I didn't want to
have this publicized
before I had a scientific
paper describing these results.
He agreed to hold
the press conference,
if he had a chance to present
the data to scientists, who
could judge it and critique it.
And I said, we can get a
group of scientists at MIT
for a seminar on Monday.
And so that became the plan.
We flew off.
Charles has got a typewriter,
which he bought in the hotel.
And he's pounding
out this manuscript
while he's flying,
because he wants
to be able to give people
a description of what
the data is.
And Charles came to
MIT, gave a seminar,
and then gave a
press conference.
Charles gets up and starts
talking about cloning the gene,
and it's all DNA and joining
and putting in bacteria
and assaying interferon.
I thought it was going to
be a big event-- you know,
cloning interferon
is something people
had been trying
to do for so long.
But what ended up was there were
a lot of critical questions,
you know, what is an
academic scientist doing
working for a company?
And the reporters aren't
getting it, so I get up,
and I take the
microphone from Charles,
and I tell the reporters why
cloning alpha interferon is
a great thing.
Then the next day on the front
page of the New York Times,
it was, you know,
Biogen cures cancer.
And so that really
set Biogen on the map
and got people really thinking
about the possibilities
of recombinant DNA.
Scientists in
Boston today claimed
a major medical breakthrough.
They said they
have used bacteria
to produce a substance
called interferon.
Interferon fights many viruses,
including those believed
to cause many forms of cancer.
It was, at the
time, quite unusual
that a biologist would be linked
to some commercial interest.
There was the ethic
that applying one's work
to common everyday uses
in clinical applications
was dirty, would somehow sully
the academic basic biomedical
research agenda.
Some of my colleagues
thought it was an awful thing
to have done, you know.
They actually called me
names for having succumbed
to this financial influence.
But MIT was different.
It derived from a
decades-long ethos
at MIT, where one had
encouraged electrical engineers
and computer engineers to
apply what they had learned
to everyday practicalities that
yielded many kinds of benefit
for humanity at large.
The concept of, should
a university be working
with industry, will the grubby
fingerprints of industry soil
the ivory tower of academia--
MIT didn't have to go through
that, because they weren't
set up as an ivory tower.
MIT started off with the
charter of bringing science
to industry and agriculture.
So the faculty were
working with industry
probably since MIT
opened its doors in 1865.
They were starting
companies all along.
Interferon doesn't really have
much effect on lots of cancers,
but it does have
an effect, and it
became a more than a
billion dollar a year drug.
It was sold for a
particular type of leukemia,
but more importantly, for
hepatitis C. And for years,
it was the only, really,
treatment for hepatitis C.
After this discovery,
scientists all around the world
who were working
in the field began
to think about the
commercial aspects of it
rather than just the
academic aspects of it.
In a sense, the entire
industry starts from one or two
companies--
Genentech on the west
coast, Biogen here.
You know, there are now
2,000, 3,000 companies.
It's infection.
The growth of the industry, in
large part, is by infection.
People see it's possible.
It was not planned.
Most of the biotech
companies, virtually all,
were started by
faculty entrepreneurs.
The company that I
helped start, Genzyme,
focused on making
recombinant enzymes that
could be used to treat
certain genetic disorders,
such as Gaucher disease.
I have seven grandchildren,
and one of them
has Gaucher and has been
treated with the drug
his grandfather helped develop.
My name is Andrew Steinert.
I'm 16 years old, and I
attend Belmont High School.
Gaucher disease is a disease in
which the body cannot degrade
a particular glycolipid, a
particular fatty substance.
It affects the
liver and the spleen
and the bones and
things like that.
He used to have to
go to the hospital
every three weeks
to get an infusion.
He now gets it at home,
and he simply sits and does
his homework while they put
the line in and transfuse
in the medicine.
Every ethnic group has
its own genetic diseases,
because one person
develops a genetic disease,
and then unknowingly, various
descendants of that person
have a child together, and you
get two bad copies of the gene,
and you have a disease.
That's what happened
with Gaucher.
We were very fortunate to have
the Genzyme drug in place,
clearly.
And it also started me working
on trying to develop solutions
for other rare diseases.
Biotechnology can enable him
to leave a really symptom-free,
carefree life despite
having Gaucher's.
He's never been sick.
He's very healthy,
very energetic.
This summer, I plan to
bike across the country
from Savannah, Georgia
to Los Angeles,
California over six weeks.
It's about 85 miles a day.
It sounds crazy, but I
look forward to doing it.
[CHEERING]
The exciting thing
is once you make
an advance of that
nature in medicine,
it's an advance forever.
It's that culture, the culture
of faculty entrepreneurs,
that's the key.
And that's what really
drove Kendall Square.
Kendall Square
actually has a history
that dates back into the
post-industrial revolution.
It was once a geography
that was deeply involved
in manufacturing.
In the 1950s and 1960s,
New England as a whole
experiences an industrial slump.
Many of the businesses
that made East Cambridge
such a vibrant neighborhood
either close or relocate.
What was left behind
in Kendall Square
was a barren wasteland of
former manufacturing facilities.
NASA was in a very expansive
mood in this early period.
It had just been
created in 1958,
and building some
new research centers.
And one of those that
they felt was essential
was a research center
to study electronics.
It was proposed that
Cambridge be the site.
There were over 100
takings by the government
to consolidate parcels,
raze them, and prepare them
for a competitive bid
that Massachusetts
was in the middle of, which
was for the location of NASA.
People thought for
many years that this
is what the future
of Cambridge would
look like-- a hub of aerospace,
research, and technology
for years to come.
But then that plan
never comes to fruition.
President Richard
Nixon, concerned
by the deficits and the costs
associated with the Vietnam
War, decided to make significant
cuts in the national budget.
Among those cuts was the
electronics research center.
It left behind the cleared
land and a lot of parking lots.
By the late 1970s, MIT is not
only sitting inside of a city,
but it's also sitting next
to an area of land that
is effectively vacant.
And that is the land where a lot
of the first biotech companies
that want to locate
next to MIT move into,
and they find office space.
They find buildings
that have strong floors
and high ceilings, so they
can sort of do flexible lab
configurations in.
And we just got lucky
here in many respects.
If they hadn't torn down
all those factories,
if the land hadn't
been vacant, would it
have developed the same way?
At the time, people thought
that was an enormous loss.
But in retrospect, it was a
silver lining behind a cloud,
because it made an
awful lot of space
available in the
subsequent decades
for the building
of, for example,
the Whitehead Institute.
Jack Whitehead had
developed a company
to make scientific
equipment, and so he
wanted to build a
research institute that
would be his gift to
the research community.
There were people
who were suspicious
that the White
Institute was somehow
a vehicle for enabling
Jack Whitehead to fund
his own biotech
investment ventures.
This is a business
guy, an industrialist
who made a fortune
out of innovation.
He's going to look to skim off
all the innovation that comes
out of this research institute.
The Boston Globe
published a series
of articles that sort of
inflamed the Boston area.
This was a bit of out of
control paranoia, and, in fact,
Whitehead was accused
of all manner of things.
Here he was trying to
do something totally
philanthropic, and he
couldn't convince people
that it was totally
philanthropic.
Academic Council discussed
it, and then voted it down,
and they voted it down
by a huge margin, by 85%.
As Whitehead observed
later, making money
was much easier
than giving it away.
He was giving us the opportunity
to move a little closer
to medicine without
having a medical school.
And so I had to convince
my colleagues that that's
what was going to happen, and
not what the Boston Globe said
was going to happen.
And after it had
had a full hearing
for a year and a half of
discussion on the ground,
it then went back
to Academic Council
and was voted in
approval by 85%.
And in the end, we
got a piece of land
right next to the MIT
campus, and we built it.
We were the pioneer
building there, yes.
By 1990, the Whitehead Institute
is perceived and acknowledged
as, perhaps, the
world's leading research
center in molecular biology.
It was that fast.
The Whitehead
Institute's excellence
is due to the vision
of David Baltimore.
He could sense talent, and
when people like Eric Lander
came along, he saw Lander to
be a very intelligent person.
Here was a guy who had no
formal training in genetics,
in biology, in medicine.
He was not really a biologist.
He was a mathematician.
And Eric decided
that he was going
to leave behind much of
his mathematical career
and his business career and
become a geneticist just
at the time when there were the
first discussions of sequencing
the human genome.
This heady idea that
when we could barely
sequence a couple
hundred letters of DNA
after a long day's
work, we might read out
the entire human genetic
code captured the imagination
of a young new generation
of which I was part.
And it just changed
all our lives.
Very quickly, we formed
the Whitehead MIT Center
for Genome Research.
That becomes one of
the key enterprises
in the larger human
genome sequencing project.
Somewhere in the neighborhood
of 1/3 of the human genome
was sequenced here at MIT.
Suddenly, it meant instead
of wandering forever
trying to look for one gene
that's causing a disease,
you had an inventory of
all 20,000 human genes.
You could see their locations.
You could map their inheritance.
You could begin to
collect not just
one genome, but by
using it as a scaffold,
all the variation in
the human population.
It sort of turned on the lights.
We could look around, and
we could see everything.
That genome center
became a magnet
for smart, young,
PhDs and MDs who
all knew that this was an
important part of the future
of biology, and thus
was born the idea
of creating the Broad Institute.
And as a result of all
this, what ended up
within a radius of 150 yards--
four extraordinary
institutions--
the core MIT Biology
Department, the Koch Institute,
the Broad Institute, and
the Whitehead Institute.
And, of course, up the street is
the McGovern Institute focused
essentially on the brain
and nervous system,
and also the Picower Institute.
All of these benefit, I think,
from the initial gamble that
was taken with the Whitehead.
In the 20th century,
we treated diseases
based on their symptoms.
What's happened in
the 21st century
is all of medicine
is getting rethought
in terms of the fundamental
causes of disease--
the genes that are mutated, the
specific cellular mechanisms
that are deranged.
And it means that
targeted therapies
based on a real
mechanistic understanding
have become the norm.
And because of that,
hundreds and hundreds
of new kinds of drugs
are being developed.
Thousands and thousands of
clinical trials are being run.
And we're beginning to see
truly remarkable responses.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I think the most
remarkable to me
is the idea that we
can do gene therapy
and cure certain
genetic diseases,
that we can do genome
editing and take
on things like sickle
cell anemia or blindness.
Within 8, 10, 15
years, you saw lots
of these companies springing
up to develop therapeutics
for a whole host
of human diseases
that we couldn't even
think about treating even
just a few years before.
If you go back 30
years, I don't think
there was a single large
pharmaceutical company
in Massachusetts.
And now, of course,
there's everybody here.
The large companies started
setting up offices and research
labs in Boston to observe,
partner, and, in some cases,
buy these small biotech
companies to add
to their stable of
pharmaceuticals.
Novartis was the first
pharmaceutical company
to invest in the
Cambridge ecosystem,
long before it was the mega
cluster that it is today.
The architecture of our
research headquarters
started to grow, first in the
Necco Wafer factory that is now
the headquarters of our
cancer drug hunting,
culminating in 2016, where we
opened these two new buildings,
completing more than a million
square feet of lab space.
Our pipeline has 340
drug discovery projects,
90 clinical stage molecules, and
more than 500 clinical trials.
Most pharmaceutical
companies now
have deeply embedded
collaborations, but also
physical footprints here.
And the biotech ecosystem
is just absolutely thriving.
Pfizer moves into Cambridge.
Sanofi buys Genzyme,
and Millennium
starts on human genomics.
Vertex comes out of
Harvard, and now we're
seeing Google and
Microsoft and Amazon,
so Kendall Square has
now taken on the patina
of being high tech, strong
biological, IT, big data
center.
And some of them have been
unbelievably successful.
I mean I would think the
market capitalization must
be on the order of a
trillion dollars, maybe more.
It's a little like
a chemical reaction.
Two reactants may
react a little bit,
but if you have a lot of
them, all of a sudden,
the concentration
drives the reaction.
Kendall Square
has now become one
of the very most
expensive places,
if you think about real estate
costs, per square foot rents.
I think it's on par with
Times Square in Manhattan.
That's because everybody
wants to be here.
LabCentral is a really
interesting innovation
in and of itself.
There was a recognition that
these tech incubators are
fantastic, but what the
life sciences really needs
is wet lab incubators, a
completely different animal.
There's often what's referred
to as the valley of death
between research in a university
and a successful company.
And the reason is the
cost of building a lab can
be millions of dollars.
So what we discovered was that
if we shared the resources,
and you brought all the
entrepreneurs together,
not only could they get
a very efficient access
to the physical infrastructure
that they needed
to kind of get through that
valley of death at a lower cost
and hopefully not
die, but they also
found that they were
around other people doing
the same thing.
The people that traverse
the valley of death
are the ones that sort of,
like, hold hands and get across
through advice or connections.
That's actually
what Kendall Square
is really good at is
sort of like holding
hands across that valley.
The vast majority
of biotech companies
never are profitable from
selling any kind of drugs.
That's not their goal.
Their goal is to take a piece of
intellectual property, a patent
or an idea for a new
therapy, and develop it
to the point where a big
pharma company will look at it
and say, gee, this has promise.
We will buy it up or
license the technology,
and we will take it through
all the way to approval.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Today is our Amgen Pitch It
for a Golden Ticket Event.
Once a year, we
award two companies
a golden ticket which gives them
free bench space at LabCentral
for one year.
And so we had 44
companies applied.
We selected six to do the
pitch, and we'll actually
hand out the two winners of
the golden ticket this evening.
We are standing on the
quite literal precipice
of a true revolution in
the way we treat cancer.
Our first product is a
biodegradable minimally
invasive implantable
patch that we can embed
with the powerful toxic agents.
These onco-selective
messenger RNAs
are delivered into cancer
cells and healthy cells
with lipid nanoparticles,
just like a cancer vaccine.
Just giving these guys the
first step on the ladder
is very critical.
Sometimes that can
be the hardest part.
It's a non-viral
transfection technology
in which cells are flowing
through a microchannel.
[APPLAUSE]
And now for the fun part,
it's time for us to vote.
You can choose which
company that pitched tonight
that you think should win one
of Amgen's next golden tickets.
We're looking for an
exciting innovation.
We're here in Kendall Square,
which is the innovation
capital of the world.
But we're also very interested
in looking at technologies,
approaches that would align
with Amgen's overall broader
strategy.
And so that allows us to
partner up our scientists
with our Golden Ticket
winners to help mentor
them, to help them navigate
some of the key questions
that they have in
the early phase.
So without further
ado, I'm going
to introduce the first Golden
Ticket is being awarded
to PanTher Therapeutics.
Yay!
[MUSIC PLAYING]
We are a spinoff of MIT.
We are fundraising right now
and getting the validation
and the approval from
big companies like Amgen,
it really makes the difference
in the way investors
and the community can
see our technology,
because it's pre-vetted by
big players in the space.
[INAUDIBLE]
One thing that's an accelerator
about this community
is that there's a lot of shared
experience and shared wisdom.
So when I have an idea
for a new company,
I don't have to learn
everything from scratch.
I can go across the hall, and
I can say, is this a good idea?
Has this been tried?
What's the path forward?
Do you know an
investor I can talk to?
Will you be on my board?
How much money do
you think I need?
Is this the right moment?
You know, all of
those questions.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
One of the impacts of
Kendall Square that I've seen
is that kids here
of all backgrounds
will have opportunities
to be exposed
to this kind of research
and get involved in it.
The Rindge School
of Technical Arts
is the technical arm of this
comprehensive high school.
You could take anything from
biotechnology, engineering,
computer science to culinary,
carpentry, business.
The biotech program here
is building a pipeline
of students who then
pursue life sciences
and become workers in this
very dynamic and exciting field
of biotechnology in Cambridge.
What happens in
industry when there's
an issue with, say,
food poisoning, right?
So we'll transfer 15
of the B into the Bx.
Today, we were trying to find
foods that were contaminated
with the pathogenic
E. coli bacteria,
and the way we're able to do
that is that we used polymerase
chain reaction, PCR,
and restriction enzymes
in order to find a certain
amount of base pairs
that we could use to find
where the pathogen was.
See how he's anchoring
and stabilizing?
That's a good practice.
When we run it in
the gels, we could
see, based on the marks
that it leaves behind,
which food sample does contain
the pathogenic E. coli.
So let's capture that image
and put this in your notebooks,
so you can write this up.
A lot of the techniques,
things like PCR, Bradford
assays, I think a
lot of those skills
are skills I can take
to an agricultural job
that I want to do focusing on
the sciences in particular.
I've really become confident
in moving around and working
in the lab.
I've gotten to meet,
like, a lot of people who
are in the scientific
careers who are
willing to help and mentor me.
When students have this training
in these basic lab skills,
they are very
attractive candidates
for companies and
research institutes
that offer opportunities
for high schoolers.
Oh, my god.
That is gorgeous.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Pretty much steadily
since the 1950s on,
molecular biology
has continued to grow
in its power exponentially.
Every time you think, oh,
it's gotta be topping off,
you wake up, and
something else has
fired another booster rocket to
get it into even higher orbit.
The most transformational
technologies
of the 20th century are
digital technologies,
and I believe that the
convergence of biology
with engineering will
be the technology
story of the 21st century.
The advances in
quality of life were
the result of convergence
between engineering
and the sciences.
Now we're adding life
sciences to the mix,
and that is creating
an explosive benefit
to society in particular to the
medical domain and health care.
I'm a chemical engineer, and
I work in polymer science.
We design large
molecules, which are
able to interact with a
number of natural materials
like proteins and DNA.
We're building a staged
nanoparticle attack.
It is a one-two punch that we
can deliver on a tumor cell
to disable it, and then kill it.
The next 10, 20,
30 years is going
to be a massive shift based on
what machine learning and AI
can do, even more than
genomes, even more
than all the other things
that have happened.
This is something that can
really, really change the game.
Biotechnology has only had
a modicum of the impact
that it's going to have.
Qualitative changes
in medicine are
going to come with the
use of genes for therapy,
and that's just beginning.
It's inconceivable that
people could figure out
how to manipulate the immune
system to kill cancer.
It's Everest.
I mean-- and the
fact is that many
of the companies
in Kendall Square,
there are people climbing
Everest every day.
The real impact is that
we can cure diseases
we couldn't cure before.
I mean things that were death
sentences aren't anymore.
I think it's pretty
unlimited what's
going to happen in
Kendall in terms
of biotech, genetic
therapies, various RNA
therapies, and CRISPR
cellular therapies, tissue
engineering, digital medicine,
artificial intelligence,
nanotechnology.
I think it's pretty unlimited.
That kind of revolution doesn't
occur very often in history.
And to have had the opportunity
to live through all of that
is a wonder.
This moment in
biomedical science--
I saw it happen.
I helped lead it.
It's changing the world.
It's just been an absolute
fantasy of a life.
[MUSIC PLAYING]